アメリカンドッグ党政治に串を刺し小麦粉などで作った衣をつけて油で揚げた食品の
和製英語の名称
日本では縁日や祭りなどの屋台学園祭の模擬店高速道路のサービスエリアやプール遊園
地などの野外遊技場などの売店コンビニエンスストアなどで行く販売され
僕多分ここ最近で一番食べているものがアメリカ
家族でおいしい非常に美味しいんですけども僕はここだろう
コンビニに売ってるとほぼ100%アメリカンとかいます肇社長です
僕がそこで思ったわけですよアメリカンドってどこのコンビニもほぼ100%
アメリカンドッグが降っているとの中でどのアメリカンとかが一番美味しいのかってね
ぼく思ったわけですよ
というわけで集ようなコンビニのアメリカンだ
で全部買ってきました
本当に大変なんですよそのコンビニ今アメリカンドッグがってるわけでもないからさ
10勝部たやこれだけ本目の食べ比べシリーズあると思うんですけどもこれであのね
それまでが大変だからねこれ全部のコミュニティを回ってきたからねそれも今できたて
だから大変だったけどやりたかったよいま5号の惨事ですけどまぁ何も食べません壁前
にアメリカンドッグを全部の子
に探してもらった母校
めてくださいまずだしてみましょうか入ってゆけ各店頭の代表をチン発に並んで
いただきました僕はこれからこの落ちんっ
しょっっ4敗という間に並んでいただきましたこちらのコーンです
値段的にはね基本的に108円と木の床もどこも108円なんだけどサークルk だけ
120段サークルk だけちょっと高いみたいです
セブンイレブンのそうするこちらローソンですか
ファミリーマートサークルk だけこのパッチンでできないタイプです
ミニストップさあもうこっちだはいはいこの時点でひとつ謎に気づきました
そうアメリカンドックのケチャップパンのバスターがサークルk 以外全部
キューピー株式会社
つまりサークルk 以外のこのケチャップは基本的に同じ倍率的にはどこも一緒ですね
ろーそんだけがちょっとそんなか
いい感じであとは基本的に同じでございますイヤホン時にアメリカンドッグ
めちゃくちゃ今ハマってますからねなんだろうこのサクッとしたこのあの3の中に
溢れるこのソーセージで浅く食べ比べてみましょう
マークはコンビニといえばこちらセブンイレブンでございます色ですねこんがり
きつね色に焼けておりますデザインフォルム文句打者腹な曲線美衣もサクサクしており
思う
よしっかってありますでオナいる
あっついでございますまずはセブンイレブンをいただきます
うまうま今江前コラボが甘いですソーセージのしっとりしていてすごい食べやつなんで
だろう
お腹減ってるからかなめちゃくちゃ嬉しいです子供サクサクというとふわふわ系ですね
ちょっとミルキーなんでやさしい味わいが楽しめます
ごちそうさまでしたさすが大だというベッカっていうかそのそんな名鑑ドックおいしい
よいやもうねぇ
もういいんじゃねぇか仲良い考えるようなみーなー今回の動画でアメリカンドック4
ナンバーを極める道は必ず食べますけど全部
吉田ツイ廃論ですフォルム的には少し中細めでやってちょっとカリカリ感が漂ってます
ねそうそう言い
被弾しそうだった働きます
んんパワー
お市となんかなまぁ生的な子を生かしました
なーんて切ってなんだ不思議な味わいですから通学するインプレッションね
でも美味しいですね
踊ろうも[ __ ]なんだろうなダメージ家族食べるねこう
ぬねがねこんなさん恨むんですよそういう意味じゃねそういう意味じゃねーよね
ちょっと胸いっぱいになるというか幸せな気持ちになります
うまいローソンまで結構付のフィット濃縮しててうっまー
何言ってんだ俺好みの問題ですにょ
てくるバグってくれてからローソンですさんの説明にもなんねえな
ファミリーマートアメリカンドックで結構ずっしり系ですねしばかれた痕が残っており
ますさあまあファミリーマートのアメリカンドックはなんといってもこちらですね
当たりが出たらもう1本もらえると創造姫
ぜひんだ当たりが出てほすぃいいただきます
これいいよああ
うわぁ
精いっぱい楽しいんだよいやおいしいやおいしいと思うけど正直に混ぜるにはわかん
ねー
お腹いっぱいなんだもんですあっはぁ
コザぶっぱ
花が肌が花がいっぱいでじゃあおいしいよ
次に朝次サークルk 払いっていうのはサークルk ハウスの安倍ちゃんトップです
唯一キューピーの自分から解放され仕込むケチャップマスタードを果たしてどのような
的にご見せてくれるんでしょうか実に開けづらいここが食べるベンディング敷いても
作業して欲しかったところでございますがマスタードが出ないこの時私は感じだ
ああああああ
これを作った人
天才だ多摩こうなっちゃいますよああああっ
あ
なんじゃこりゃー
なんと一歩やらいやはございません
ああああああ
豪華ちょっと後方は多かった次はミニストップのアメリカンドックです
あおいしそうな匂いがしますねそう最後は俺を喰えばどうアメリカンと9月はおいしい
か分かるるしかねーだろ
和装右トップの女が乗っていただきます
ああ
ん
re ん
グッズの様でした itv で後ソイナメリ監督食べ終わりました
格付けといきましょう17位レベル
天一になったというとしてはそうですねまぁ最初に食べたからおいしかったです第二
労組6割でございまーす2番目に食ったっていうのが大きかったですね美味しく食べれ
ました
第3位
他の3つネストめでとうございます
ん
ぷっ